manifestement il veut écouter personne
il est tout seul il a tous les syndicats
contre lui et la 70 à 80 % des Français
contre lui mais ils sont peut-être dans
cette direction donc il faut se
mobiliser pour l'empêcher de le faire 65
ans c'est pas un totem ça n'est pas un
totem je le redis il y a d'autres
solutions qui peuvent permettre aussi
d'atteindre ce qui est notre objectif
l'équilibre de notre système de retraite
à l'horizon 2030 si il est le report de
l'âge légal de départ en retraite qui
est annoncé à 65 ou 64 ans la CFDT fera
ce que nous disons depuis le début
c'est-à-dire nous opposerons à cette
réforme notamment nous mobilisons en
appelant les salariés à mobiliser des
aides pour les boulangers confrontés à
l'explosion de leur facture énergétique
annonce du ministre de l'économie Bruno
Le Maire ce matin qui met la pression
sur les fournisseurs d'énergie qu'il
reçoit en ce moment nous avons un
certain nombre de dispositifs ils ne
sont pas suffisamment connus et je
voulais saisir cette rencontre cette
nouvelle rencontre avec les
représentants des boulangers pour
rappeler tous les dispositifs qui sont
déjà
disposition des boulangers et qui ne
sont pas suffisamment utilisés malgré le
report même malgré les flottement le
même des impôts ou enfin des charges et
de cette facture est-ce que je vais
pouvoir m'en sortir par rapport à mon
entreprise à mon échelle et celle de mes
collègues est-ce que ça va être parce
que ça va passer est-ce qu'il est
malheureusement déjà pas trop tard pour
moi et moi je dirais mon conseil à tous
ceux qui nous écoutent c'est
signalez-vous appelez votre énergéticien
allez sur le site de votre fournisseur
d'énergie appeler vos services des
impôts ça a l'air d'être un peu bizarre
d'appeler son service des impôts pour
avoir des aides il se trouve qu'ils ont
tous les guichets d'aide et que ils
peuvent vous accompagner maintenant pour
vous dire c'est suffisant pour une
facture qui va passer multipliée par 10
ou 12 évidemment non mais rien ne sera
suffisant c'est à dire qu'une entreprise
même avec toutes les aides ou les
reports si ces multiplié par 10 ça sera
pas possible les entreprises
fournisseurs d'énergie
accepter d'examiner au cas par cas
lorsque les factures ont augmenté de
manière prohibitive une résiliation des
contrats sans frais pour renégocier des
contrats plus avantageux pour les
entreprises qui ont été confrontées à
des hausses de prix tout à fait
prohibitives qui menacerait la survie de
leur entreprise et on ne sort pas du
système tarifaire européen on se fait
enfumer par les Allemands depuis des
mois mais on sort pas du système pour
faire plaisir aux allemands alors que
les Espagnols et les Portugais sont
sortis parce que mes amis allemands ça
leur fait pas plaisir non plus donc il y
a quelque chose donc on fermait leur
centrales et c'est nous qui payons
l'addition absolument donc on est nul
oui complètement on est méprises
c'est un scandale français absolument
Sergi qui augmente mais également les
produits nécessaires au traitement de
l'eau comme le chlore le prix du mètre
cube passerait ainsi de 4,26 à 4,80 €
une hausse sur l'année de près de 65
euros pour une famille de quatre
personnes le budget n'est pas encore
voté mais la communauté d'agglomération
Ardennes métropole c'est pas la seule à
envisager une augmentation à deux
chiffres c'est également le cas à
Clermont-Ferrand et toi notamment le
président du Rassemblement national
Jordan Bardella envoie une lettre au
boulanger quel paradoxe de voir le
président de la République se réjouit de
l'inscription de la baguette au
patrimoine de l'Unesco d'Ital mais le
condamné par son inaction des milliers
d'artisans boulangers a fermé le rideau
pris à la gorge par une inflation hors
de contrôle ce morceau de la ville de
schaerboro dans le nord de l'Angleterre
tout le week-end du Nouvel An qu'est-ce
qu'il faisait il ronflait il a l'air
très heureux et il est relaxe l'animal
baptisé tort se réagit de 3 à 5 ans et
serait en bonne santé on essaye de dire
autre chose on essaie de faire un nuage
de fumée autour de la promotion de ce
film mais ce qui est clair c'est pas ce
que je dis qu'on attaque
c'est moi et c'est pas un problème trop
tard les gars cette
errance selon les spécialistes seraient
probablement dû au réchauffement
climatique et à la fonte des glaces
arctiques